esta movilización partió desde varios
puntos del Oeste de Caracas rumbo al
cuartel de la montaña donde reposan los
restos del fallecido presidente Hugo
Chávez en nuestro recorrido pudimos
constatar que ya no se trataban de
concentraciones multitudinarias como
antes se veían eran pocas personas
varias tiras durante todo el recorrido y
en su mayoría funcionarios públicos
identificados en sus logos con el
Ministerio de infraestructura de ciencia
y tecnología la cante B transporte entre
otros más temprano se realizó un
homenaje en el cuartel de la montaña una
ceremonia más privada que contó con la
participación de los familiares más
cercanos de Hugo Chávez su madre sus
hijos y también el alto mando militar y
ella estuvieron presentes los
expresidentes de Bolivia Evo Morales de
Honduras Manuel Zelaya de Cuba Raúl
Castro y el presidente de Nicaragua
Daniel Ortega en su discurso el hermano
de Hugo Chávez llamaba a la unión como
una forma de homenaje arlo las personas
que participan de esta movilización
insisten en que el legado de Chávez está
más presente que nunca sin embargo es
una realidad y analistas coinciden en
que la administración de Nicolás maduro
ha intentado apartarse de la imagen de
Chávez para construir su propio modelo
su propio lenguaje y su propio proyecto
hoy en día Venezuela es un país sumido
en una crisis económica importante donde
la mayor parte de la población no tiene
acceso a la canasta básica